did you grow up in the US um I was born
in the US I actually grew up in but here
in Brazil and but I would spend the
summer's here so I was kind of back and
forth between my mom and my dad and yeah
there is worse so I started began my
journey with martial arts at age six I
started training and Chinese martial
arts and so on mostly like when Sun
based martial arts but I I always sort
of looked at every style because I felt
like every system so that had something
to offer so uh so yeah I was definitely
influenced a lot by Hong Kong cinema you
know growing up watching films from Hong
Kong Korea and all these different
countries and so that's kind of like
when my love for film came from like
just a lot of those old classic action
films from back in the day like jet Li
Jackie Chan you know Donnie Yen you know
people like that so yeah I guess my
career in film sort of grew out of that
I grew out of other martial arts you
know where did your love for martial
arts start like what was the reason you
got into it um my dad my dad was a
martial artist and so it was it was
something that you the minute you could
walk like it was imperative you start
training that sort of thing so yeah
before I knew I even loved it it was
something that was sort of given to me
as a gift which I really appreciate
because it definitely shaped I guess my
whole life when it comes down to it
martial arts led to film and it also
gave me like a very zen-like
way that he liked the way that I am I
said I'm very zen and very calm
most of filmmaking is like
troubleshooting and you have to stay
calm and it's important that no one sees
you freak out or anything like that so
I'm like I'm very steady on set and um
that discipline that focus it all like
came from martial arts oh so you would
live in Brazil part-time and then come
back to LA was it no no I lived in the
South for a while loop in South Carolina
and then many years later moved to
Atlanta Georgia and then came here so
yeah so it started in the south so it
was a interesting culture shock to sort
of grow up not not combative but I was I
was very uh i had a very militarized
mentality i guess and to sort of go from
that to being like a black sheep you
know in the south and because i was
always a kid who wanted to when
everybody wanted to run out and party
like i was like now i'm gonna work on
this script or i'm gonna right here i'm
gonna train there i'm gonna you know you
know so no one understood what i was
doing like nobody understood like you
know this this thing i was doing like
with filming I was already proclaiming
like from a young age like like yeah I
want to be a filmmaker and and yeah
nobody got it nobody at the time you
know nobody no one
instead it you say militarized your
father was in the military yes yeah
that's where the martial arts training
came from and that's sort of yeah so he
he instilled in me like a very I had a
very rigid very structured upbringing
and so I walked around in combat boots
and all black all this
and yeah I just had a very unique way of
looking at the world but but that
discipline like really helped me a lot
like um it really helped me to to focus
and like I'm like I've never drank I've
never had a drink I've never smoked you
know and these are decisions that came
about when I was like super young you
know so and I never deviated from so
yeah I think all that discipline it
certainly certainly made a difference
you know
so you were one kid in Brazil and then
you fly to the south and everything
changes for however long you're there
how are you dealing with that on a daily
basis it was it was tough honestly like
I was very introverted and I was I felt
super isolated in a lot of ways because
um I just felt like nobody really
understood the way that I thought nobody
really understood you know until
eventually I had like a high school
sweetheart or whatever she brought me
out of my shell but up to that point I
was always thinking so people thought I
was angry all the time but I wasn't I
was just very like intensely focused on
like what I wanted to do which was like
be a filmmaker
yeah did you get picked on no cuz they
they saw your martial arts training yeah
they knew better I had I had a incident
to happen and then very quickly it gets
around you know me but what was
interesting about that too is um I've
always been a teacher like I've always
had students you know even as a young
kid like I always found myself in
positions where I was like leading young
men or like teaching them in or being
somebody who guided a lot of people like
I would always in part
information a lot of times through
martial arts I always found myself
teaching like I've always had the heart
of like a teacher I always wanted to
share information and yeah I think that
was something too that was like really
really close to my heart like just just
being able to share information with
people even even to this day I always
have a lot of people that I mentor and
that I like to share information with
because I feel like I feel like that's
what it's for
I feel like information is to be shared
didn't you know if there's a way that
you can help someone or give someone
more knowledge about something than they
had the day before I think that's that's
a great gift to give to people so I
really love teaching like in whatever
capacity I'm thinking about I'm starting
to teach some seminars this year like I
think I'm going to start doing that on
film and writing yeah yeah probably like
action on screen you know how to how to
captured choreographed action sequences
how to produce projects from start to
finish
more more practical ways to do it yeah I
think I think that's something I'm going
to do starting this year
when did you move to Los Angeles 2009 I
think it was Oh during the recession
maybe 2009 but that was fun yeah yeah I
was I was fortunate though I had I had
some really good friends here
Andra McCoy who's also a stuntman and a
martial artist and an actor yeah we were
friends and yeah he was like hey man
just come on out like you could stay
here just cut out and you know cuz I
told him like at the time I'd been
living in Atlanta for quite a few years
and I'd done I produced like two feature
films out there and at the time I was
the only one sort of doing action you
know there were a lot of people doing a
relationship dramas like Tyler Perry
type films and stuff like that so I got
like a lot of recognition really fast
because I was just doing something
different and so yeah I did a few films
out there and a couple a couple other
projects out there directors for
projects and I felt like I had done all
that I could there like I felt like I
sort of reached the ceiling out there as
far as I could go so I knew it was time
to come here you know I mean what was
that moment where you felt that like was
it just where you were feeling stagnant
well it was it was after the release of
my second film was called champion Road
arena and at the time I had I had two
movies that were released worldwide
through distribution they had done
really well for me and I just felt like
I needed to be where things were really
happening like I needed to there were a
lot of calls that I'd gotten a lot of
interest I gotten but they were like
well can you meet tomorrow I was like
well
kind of in Atlanta you know that type of
things so it was the need to sort of be
able to make things sort of happened in
the moment because when they happen they
would happen quickly and I wasn't I'll
be like well give me a few days and you
know that type of thing so I was like
yeah I really feel like I've done all
that I can do here
and I just really need to be where
everything is is going on everything's
happening yeah so was it was inevitable
to move to LA was never like it it uh it
was always in the cards as well so yeah
I think I just felt like it was time you
know so you're you're moving out here
it's 2009 nobody kind of knows what's
going on it's they don't know how bad
everything's gonna get that's more
uncertainty yeah I think everybody was
feeling it no matter yeah how supposedly
stable their situation was yeah yeah I
had a plan though I mean because I'm
very much like that I like to plan I
like to sort of have a direction that
I'm going in and certain steps that I
want to take this sort of go where I
want to be and I guess it comes from
when I started out like I started at 15
I started writing directing shooting
crafting and editing you know I started
a really early
shooting on Betamax and so the way I
figured out how to create an editing
system for my films was I would take two
Betamax
machines to put them together
pop pop the raw food like I'd shoot on
Betamax and I popped out that that raw
footage in the top player on the bottom
player I'd put an empty tape in there
and so and running all through the
television and so I would use the pause
and play button
to actually cut on my short on to the on
to the the empty tape you know so I
learned to get really precise because if
you make a mistake you have to start all
over again and recut the whole thing so
I used like two Betamax machines to edit
and then I ran a boom box into the
Betamax machines into the television and
I had like all my cassette tapes kind of
queued up with music and I would have to
at the exact moment I would have to pop
the tape in and play it and record the
music onto my short films you know so I
just kind of cooked cooked up this
elaborate way to to make these short
films these little five-minute
ten-minute little shorts and I was sort
of out of necessity I was sort of used
to doing everything myself I would have
to write the short I would use my
friends and we would see it on the
weekends and then throughout the week
you know would edit and put the music on
and bothered by the next week and I
would have like a short film everybody
sit around and watch it so yeah I always
sort of had that mentality of sort of
having my hands in every part of the
process I'm still very much like that
today like any time I produce a project
my company produces a film or anything
like that I'm like super hands-on I do
like a lot of freelance work and those
are the times when I'm just directing or
something like that and things move
considerably slower you know on those
bigger projects like you know I'm used
to moving quickly and being like super
efficient but yeah I think that's that's
really why I'm able to get done as much
as I do now is because I started that
way I started with having to do so much
myself just out of necessity and then
yeah it's interesting dude is like the
first camera I ever bought like a so in
15 I'll put this camera on layaway it
was a it was Japanese this Betamax
camera it wasn't in English so nobody
wanted it you know me and so um that was
the only reason I could afford it
because it was so cheap because nobody
would buy this thing and so um I bought
it I took it home and then I I made
myself like a table of contents like I
would push a button and see what it does
and then whatever that whatever it did I
would just write that down like oh okay
that must be rewind and this must be
play and this must be you know and sort
of like made myself a table of contents
to use the camera until I learned all
the symbols and learn what they did and
yeah that's how I started making my
first choice with this Japanese camera
that nobody wanted yeah what store was
this where you put it on layaway oh it
was a pawn shop
okay old-school pawnshop but there was
some interesting stories behind that
camera yeah it's like 11 months every
little bit of money I got I would just
put on this camera and you know but one
thing I appreciate about my parents is
they never told me I couldn't do it like
I would be like hey I'm gonna make don't
be like yep we'll be right there
watching you know like they never
discouraged me they never said like
that's ridiculous what do you you know
what are you talking about like you know
nobody ever said I couldn't so I never I
never thought there was something I
couldn't do you know
you've produced over 40 short films yeah
yeah and that's starting from age 15
until sometime like late in my 20s yeah
most of them I kind of I kind of had a
plan like I said before I started out
with like little five-minute shorts and
then sort of built to like a 10 minute
short and then to a 20 minute and then
40 minutes and then you know eventually
my first feature film and yeah a lot of
those were mostly for myself like some
mod released but most of them I just
wanted to focus on particular aspects of
filmmaking so for instance with one of
my just focus on composition you know
like another might be just lighting
another might be sound another might be
movement or being able to frame action a
particular way yeah and so like you know
I always sort of approached every aspect
of filmmaking from a separately like I'm
gonna give you guys a tip I'm gonna give
you a really important piece of
information like um one of my mentors
gave me and it was a way to sort of like
in the beginning when you're trying to
train your eye as far as cinematography
this was a tip I got that sort of took
my my cinematography from here to here
like overnight so um so what you do is
you get a binder like a five ring binder
or something like that
you go online you search Google you look
for movies that are like 100 million
dollars or more like in terms of budget
right you find close-ups you find two
shots you find masters you find all
these different frames like still still
frames from all these films the reason
you choose
million-dollar films because they can
afford like the top cinematographers in
the world right so you you section off
your binder let's say you want close-ups
so in this section you put maybe five
examples of close-ups another section
you put another five examples of two
shot or whatever over-the-shoulder
whatever and you you fill it up with
those different frames and different
sections and so from there let's say
your cinematographer you kind of knew it
you just start now and you may not
really know how to frame subjects that
great just yet so what you do is every
time you shoot you set up your tripod
you set up your camera you adjust your
frame the way you think it should be the
way you think it should look let's say
you have two people having a
conversation whatever the case is and
you want to do an over-the-shoulder shot
you adjust that frame to where you think
it should look right then you'd take out
your monitor and you go to over the
shoulder shots and then you hold that
Bhandar up you next to your your frame
and then you begin to adjust your frame
based on the composition you see in
those frames and so as you do that it's
going to slowly begin to train your eye
to have a more cinematic composition you
know I mean say yeah that's just a
little tip right there yeah I'm saying
why invest so much time in all those
shorts did you realize that you were
going to work your way up to a feature
eventually oh yeah that was feature
films was always the goal from the
beginning but I've I've always had a
very realistic approach to the industry
like I didn't expect to be able to make
transformers like my first week out you
know what I mean so I always felt like
it was the the craft it was really
important to really study it to
understand it to be a student of film to
take my time and sort of
get is technically skilled as I could
through studying through courses or
whatever it is not not be so much in a
rush to sort of just throw things out
there but you know really have a solid
foundation and really have a great
understanding of all the different
aspects of filmmaking so yeah most of
those was really just to sort of go
through the process because you've
learned so much going through the
process like it's just one thing to have
all these ideas but until you really go
through it and come up the other side
like you really don't understand it
fully you don't really know what it
takes to go from script to screen and
all those all those little things in
between and so I wanted to start from a
place where I would be comfortable to
start small not being the rest to jump
out there and make a feature but really
just focus on like the art and the
techniques of filmmaking and sort of as
you know as I'm comfortable to this sort
of branch out and make things bigger and
bigger you know so yeah it was it was it
was always in the cards to make features
but I wanted to be comfortable before
before I jumped in you know and then
ultimately on my first feature I
produced it myself I didn't ask for any
funding at all
because I felt like before I could
expect someone to invest in me I needed
to to show that I invested in myself and
I wanted to show the value of my work
you know because you know that's that's
a big thing asking someone especially
for someone you don't know asking them
to take their hard-earned money and sort
of invest in you and the
course and just looking at it from a
realistic standpoint the question would
be like well why why invest in your like
can you even make this film like this
thing you're asking me to give you money
for can you even do it like you know you
have to be able to show that you you're
capable of producing this thing that
you're asking people to pay you to make
and so I wanted to have a track record
of of work and I want a body of work
that they could see basically I want to
take all the knows away like any reason
they would have to say no I wanted to
take that away from them and so a lot of
that has to do with having a track
record having a body of work even if
it's even if you're you haven't had
anything distributed yet you know you
you haven't had any big successes there
yet to at least have a body of work that
can show consistent growth in like show
the value of what you have to offer you
know I thought it was important so when
you think back to being in Brazil and
then being in South Carolina or
somewhere in the south how are you
choosing which films you watched when
you were younger like who was
influencing you was your dad I think I
think it came from it came from martial
arts and then it then it came from my
love of storytelling you know a lot of
people think I only make access once but
I I make like every Ranger film I just
happen to love action movies because you
know something I grew up watching but
yeah I think the martial arts was the
biggest influence and but then also
films that had nothing to do with action
I just like really smart
really films up thinking man films you
know thing films that would make you
think maybe be a little unpredictable
maybe the approach to telling a story is
unique or you know sometimes it's just
how you present the idea sometimes it's
the way that you go about telling the
story visually you know there's there's
all these different ways of even if you
don't have a lot of money you can still
make something unique you can still do
something interesting and different you
know and I think a lot of times people
get too caught up on the budget and they
start to limit themselves like based on
the budget well you know I don't have
enough money to do this but maybe
there's another way you can approach
that that problem or maybe it is another
way you can approach telling the story
that could be unique that maybe it
doesn't cost a lot maybe it's in the way
you shoot it maybe it's in the way you
light it maybe it's in the way you edit
it maybe it's in the sound design
there's something like that so anytime I
create something I never I never I never
put a constraint on it based on the
dollar amount you know I try to not
think about that I try to think about in
terms of how can I approach this in an
artistic way or a visually striking way
or something like that is it a myth that
you can't make money from short films
well yeah I think now I think now
because I think things have changed so
much I think maybe 20 years ago 15 years
ago it would have been tougher but I
think that because
so many platforms now that looks for
digital content I think because you have
sort of direct-to-consumer you know you
have that now as a resource like whereas
before before social media places like
YouTube Vimeo on demand all these
different sites where you can showcase
your work and you can you can go
directly to uh consumer I think there's
ways now or you can do it like um I know
a friend of mine made a short film and I
think the short was maybe 30 minutes but
he had like a three hour course on how
he made that short film and so not only
was he selling short beast was selling
how he made it you know to mean so it
was like a little mini film school so
there's so many ways now that you can
[Music]
you know get your product to people and
if it's if it's good and people see the
value in it then they'll purchase it you
know have you had a short film of yours
purchase it's interesting because I'm
actually working on a pilot right now
I've done a lot of those sort of things
like pilot presentations I just finished
directing and shooting a pilot called
Cola was called city of Los Angeles but
colas like the abbreviation and I work
with some really great guys on that and
that's something that they're sort of
trying to start their own little
streaming platform to make like original
content and stuff like that so I just
finished that one and then I'm also
working on a pilot called I declare war
like it's like a female lead sort of
graphic novel style like action
project and we start shooting that in
April and yeah I'm actually thinking
about testing that market a little bit
like either through Vimeo on demand or
maybe some other platform I may be like
an aggregation side there's something
like that just getting it on a couple
different platforms but um
that's something I'm curious about I'm
actually exploiting myself
alright what's your process for
developing an idea I think everyone is
different sometimes you'll get just a
logline
sometimes you'll see an image sometimes
you get the name of it but not know
specifically what the story is yet
usually what I try to do is like as I
strike I have like this what does it
cost speech notes I think it is there's
a app called speech notes and so I'll
start to get information little bits and
pieces about a story
I'll start jotting them down in my phone
and usually once I kind of have a good
idea of what that story is I always
start with the outline like I anytime
before I write a script I always outline
the entire script scene one scene to
scene three and then I'll have like a
couple of a couple of lines of
information to describe the dis de scene
so this is how I like avoid writer's
block like I always outline the entire
script from front to back so when I
start writing I just write from from
from that those script notes but yeah I
usually start there I start with just a
an idea outline it
I always decide early on what the
lighting is going to be how the camera
is going to move the color every
before I even go into pre-production
like I I am I have a full idea of the
style the look of it the pacing of it
the tone of it and yeah once I do that I
start writing the script I have a team
that I work with and I usually tell them
pretty pretty early on like what the
what the concept is and how I want to
approach it and yeah I sort of I sort of
go from that you have a pretty deep
intuition yeah yeah I am I always have a
really good idea of what's gonna work I
think like you know I'm constantly
looking at the market and how I would
respond certain things and you get a
good idea of like okay this might not be
a great time to make a Western you know
versus versus hey like a superhero
thriller might feel really good right
now you know that sort of thing so yeah
I always sort of watch what the markets
doing and it's usually pretty in line
with my tastes as a as just a film goer
like the kind of stuff I like to watch
and then you have to sort of project a
few years out because it might take a
few years to get that project done so
you almost want to whatever that story
idea whatever your approach you take you
know you almost want it to be a few
years ahead of where you are so that by
the time it's all ready does it feel
stale it doesn't feel old or outdated so
yeah really protect your intuition ever
led you to something that actually
existed already like a real life story
like you were so tapped in and then you
realized oh wow that really happened and
it kind of surprising or
um not as a as yet like because I like
to be informed about things like I'm
very much
every day I'm always like seeking out
new information or are staying up on new
tech as far as filmmaking the gear and
then just like what's going on in the
world but I I do like to sort of
sometimes I like to pull things from
what's going on in the world and sort of
twist them a little bit so that so that
it is there like there is an underlying
thing that might be there concerning
something going on in the world but um I
tried to be tuning those with it you
know because I do want it to be
entertaining I try not to be overly
political because I know I know people
get sensitive about that when you put
like way too much politics in your film
people have like strong reactions to
that sort of thing so I just want to
entertain people and maybe have them see
things a little bit differently than
they may have before but I don't want to
I don't want to preach to them that sort
of thing is it hard to do that though
because right now like our culture is is
turning so much whatever side
quote-unquote side anybody's on you see
it in the youtube comment we didn't used
to see that before yeah it wasn't
brought up whatever quote side somebody
was on yeah it's super political now I
mean it's and so the thought that you
may have to as a factor of how the world
is changing and it's becoming in
us-against-them again whoever side is
them and whoever side is us yeah that's
how it seems like we're all viewing not
all of us but a lot of people what we're
kind of it's seeping into the culture so
as a father just writing about it yeah I
think um I think you can touch on some
things without
making a concrete sort of this is the
way that you know that sort of thing I
think you can touch out certain things
and and you know you can see a little
bit of that influence there without
picking without jumping on either side
you know what I mean just sort of just
present a point of view I think
and without hopefully offending anyone
it was very difficult I mean nowadays
but I usually try to deal with themes
that are more Universal so it's it's
less just sort of folk less localized
and less focused on just one particular
group or point of view and because I
think universal themes like we all can
relate to we can all connect with like a
universal themes of love wanting to
protect people you care about doing the
right thing in a lot of cases or some
people doing things that are wrong but
they feel they're justified or they feel
they're right so a lot of those sort of
overarching themes I try to play in that
spectrum you know yeah cuz I because I
want to make my films with a for like a
global market I don't want to create
things that feel too localized or too
like I'm excluding different groups of
people
you think the martial arts effected that
just the balance staying more in the
middle yeah I would I would say so I
think it's helped me in so many ways I
mean even in its the the physical part
of it is really small in comparison to
the spiritual aspect of it and then
to discipline the self discipline the
sort of you know the the way that you
sort of see everyone as being like we're
closer we're more like than we think we
are you know what I mean and being a
teacher for so many years like having so
many different people that you interact
with and you become really close with
you start to realise that and I think I
think that's affected the way that I
make shows as well like a lot of times
we're just super misunderstood like you
know and sometimes we're not listening
to other people we were only trying to
get our point across and we're not
seeing their point of view you know
everyone's intentions aren't bad you
know they they just might you just may
not understand their intentions and I
feel like you know that that plays
really well with that's one yeah I think
that that plays really well in film
because you know it's very uh it's all
about what you get from it and it's all
about sort of what you take from it and
and different people will take different
things from it you know what I mean so
yeah I think that's the really cool
thing about being a storyteller is like
you can tell a story and it's kind of
affect people in different ways you know
I'll never forget like my first
screening he was the first film I made
it was called champion Road and it was
back in 2006 I produced that film and
came out in 2008 and I had a screening I
like a local theater screening and this
guy came up to me afterwards it was it
was about so basically was about this
guy who his wife was
was dying and she needed an operation
and they couldn't afford it and so he he
wasn't even a fighter he was just a guy
you know but he put his he put himself
in harm's way you know to save her and
afterwards this guy came up to me and he
said man you know what like he had he's
been having issues with his wife like
they arguing and I think through it he
realized like how petty he was being and
how like how much he did care for he was
like man I'm leaving here and I'm gonna
go get my wife back and you know he was
like I just want you to know that you
know I just thought like that was it
like no matter what else happens with
this film like that was so cool so worth
it you know yeah that meant more to me
than like everything else that happened
with that movie what are the questions
you're asking yourself every time you
start to develop a story usually one of
the first things is can it be done like
right this moment you know like
depending on the how it's being funded
or depending on how I have to approach
it I always I like what I've noticed and
a lot of instances is when people go to
to make projects they always focus on
shooting it it's very few people focus
on finishing it you know what I mean
through post and everything so you
always have to consider how you're going
to finish it and so yeah if I have an
idea
it depends on how I'm gonna do it if I
if I'm getting a an investor or private
investor or if I'm going to produce it
myself I start asking myself those
questions in the case of eliezer
experiences Lazarus is a
feature film that uh well I'm just
finishing a post on right now I
partnered with Sean Riggs who's an actor
and also a producer and we sort of went
in to together as a vehicle for him he
had done a lot of great work up to that
point and but he wanted to do things
more in the action genre and so you know
we sort of developed it and the plan was
to get outside investors and not which
is what we did so so knowing that like I
started to sort of symbolize a plan
because my my goal was to sort of create
more movies in the sci-fi superhero
genre to create my own universe of
Heroes you know because I felt like
there should be more inclusion of Heroes
but I also feel like it's something that
we can do ourselves I don't feel like we
have to leave everything to Marvel or DC
like I feel like there's there's a room
for other people to create heroes of
their own I'm very much a person who
feels like you don't have to wait for
someone else I think you can you can do
it yourself you know I've always sort of
had that attitude so you know what
Lazarus we had an idea I started I
started writing and you know we started
reaching out to different finance
leaders and based on the work I'd
already done like my future I'd just
done before that call me King it we've
done like a limited theatrical it was on
Netflix and I did really well on Netflix
and a lot of other streaming platforms
and so we were sort of able to use the
momentum of that film to to fund Lazarus
and
yeah we sort of just went into that with
the idea of that being the first of many
new heroes that we'd create and then my
next feature coming up is called the
almighty street team it's based on a
comic book and a video game and the guys
that created that is five guys who sort
of had their own individual hero and
then they sort of put them all together
they met at a comic book convention and
they put all of them together into one
book and when I saw it I was just super
blown away by it and so I knew those
were going to be sort of the two
flagship heroes like in this new studio
Wonder Studios and so yeah we sort of
set out on this quest man to just bring
new heroes to the screen you know so I'm
really I'm really excited for people to
see Lazarus said you know we worked
really hard on it and you know it was it
was an interesting experience because
there's a lot of visual effects involved
it's probably due it's the most visual
effects heavy film I've done today yeah
what did your first few screenplays
teach you about screenwriting that's a
really good question I think some of my
even-even like a lot of my early films I
was a huge lover of like horror action
sci-fi action you know I always liked
sort of the more supernatural themes or
the more you know the stuff that was
sort of extraordinary because it was I
felt like there were no rules like you
could sort of in terms of story you
could say or doing
thing he wanted so a lot of those early
scripts were in that vein it was like
you know these huge epics like I learned
very quickly that when you start out as
a writer like don't write yourself into
a situation where it's something that
can't be made you know I think that's
the biggest thing I learned is uh
sometimes you need to sort of sort of
tone it down bring it back down to the
ground a little bit you know because we
can we can tend to sort of get really
extreme and really crazy with our ideas
and sometimes if you're just a writer
and you don't you don't do any other
part of the process like you can sort of
make things that are so big and so
expensive that you almost limit your
options in terms of being able to get it
made like um you can you can go too big
you know so I would say that's the thing
I learned early on like um I used to
shop a lot of scripts around and and you
know I had these bluff tea ideas you
know and when it came down to actually
making my first feature I was like okay
that's not gonna happen like we cannot
make transformers with no budget so we
got to bring this back down to reality
and so I started to shift my approach a
little bit I started to look at the
things I actually had access to versus
sort of writing about these things that
were just way too big to get made and so
I started looking at my the resources I
had and then let that influence this
story or the the way that I would write
the script for instance if if I knew
somebody with a bar or if I knew
somebody with
a garage or whatever the case is you
know I once it came to actually
producing this stuff myself I started
fooling using those resources and
developing stories around those those
things that I knew I could do and knew I
could could could get access to so that
I would set myself up to succeed you
know as far as producing these projects
and I was like I'll I started out
writing these extreme massive stories
and then I was like okay I'm gonna bring
it all the way down to the ground and
then work my way back up to making
bigger and bigger films and dinner sort
of do it that way but yeah it really
came down to like okay let's let's
really get real about what we have what
we don't have what we have access to
what we don't what we can make what we
can't you know and and kind of go from
there you know yes I think that was the
most important lesson I learned is to
you sort of have the dream and then you
have the reality and you have to operate
based on realistically where you are
what you have and this work your way up
from there yeah so you saw a movie like
tape works pretty much one location and
yeah absolutely incredible dialogue and
the interaction between the talent but
in terms of maybe some of the technique
but it was your first few screenplays
teach you about that um what was
interesting is because because of my
background of sort of doing it every
part of the process myself I had a
slightly different view of it because
when I when I write I'm already thinking
about how the scene is going to be done
how it's going to be shot
what type of shots I'll be using because
I'm also the descent of otaku fur so
yeah it definitely I think gave me a
different vantage point of of it because
as I'm writing it I know how it needs to
be shot I know how many shots I'm gonna
need you know I'm already looking at I'm
already sort of breaking it down as I'm
writing it and so I knew like as I'm
writing I know I'm able to do these
things like I know I'm able to produce
these scenes you know what I mean so I'm
able to sort of not limit myself but I'm
able to sort of be be a little more
informed about how I'm writing these
scenes like making sure that I'm not
putting anything on the page that can't
be done you know so yeah I would say
that from that from that standpoint
being the person that is gonna shoot it
who's gonna edit it you know all that
stuff informs the way that I would
approach writing a scene yeah what's the
most broke you've been in your life and
can you tell us a story about it hmm in
regards to filming yeah it's just a time
in your life probably when I made my
first movie my first feature film I
actually produced my first movie for
five hundred bucks
shot it in three weeks between my house
my neighbor's house and a friend's house
that was like around the corner
so so between like a one-block radius
like I in the way the way it happened is
sort of like I this is actually
interesting so I I had prep to do my
first movie it was it was
a whole totally different idea than what
I ended up going with I had done
pre-production for maybe two months and
it was all going to take place in like
this this really big building and the
day before we were gonna start shooting
that investor pulled out it's like Oh
something came up I can't you know I
can't do it so we'd prepped myself to
cast everybody we'd done all this prep
for two months we put like a deposit on
the location that we were going to use
the building we couldn't get the deposit
back so I think that happened on a
Saturday we were supposed to start
shooting Sunday night so I get the news
on Saturday I call up the cast between
Saturday and Sunday I spoke to everybody
I said look this is what happened and
yeah now we don't have a we don't have a
budget we don't have you know everything
we prepped for is pretty much we're at
square one now and I was like I know you
guys are ready to shoot they had already
took enough people to take enough days
and took off time to shoot a film I said
look we're gonna shoot a movie give me a
day and I will give back to you but but
come and now we I guess we we couldn't
shoot Sunday so it was going to be
Monday I said just give me a day come
Monday we're gonna start shooting so the
way I ended up shooting my first feature
was I would write the scenes that we
were going to shoot that day in the
morning the cast would show up that day
get the scenes we would go through the
scenes and basically we would shoot the
scene so that the same day they got the
scenes we shot them there were action
scenes in the film I would have to
choreograph the fights the day of and
teach it to the actors the day we shot
them so we basically
shot the film that way every single day
like I would shoot that day and then do
the work that night to prep coming into
the morning and we so we shot the whole
movie that way most of the actors had no
martial arts training but I I'm actually
developed now this is also very
interesting I've developed a way of
choreographing at fight scenes over the
years and making actors look like they
know how to fight you know and I use the
sword as it's like this chain chain
length method where you take three or
four techniques we call it an exchange
right so one exchange would be through
four techniques you teach those three or
four techniques to the actors it's sort
of a short a short burst of energy
versus like just shooting a fight
full-on and people getting tired and
then that's how accidents happened right
but you could get a short burst of
energy out of them for three or four
techniques and and then the Edit you use
the last technique of that exchange you
would use that to cut into the first
technique of the next exchange and I
actually learned that method from
looking at like when I was young you
know the barrel of monkeys where they
would have the hands that would connect
and you pull them out of the theater of
the barrel of monkeys so that's how I
learned to to choreograph and then cut
the way I would cut is I would use the
last part of datak stage as the first
move so even though you're shooting
these tiny little bursts of action when
you cut them together they seem seamless
because you always use the material from
the last punch
so I guess to simplify that if if I have
an exchange and the last the last
technique you've had exchanges are
straight punch right
the
next technique in the new exchange is
that same straight punch you know that
me so that you're able to carry that
over and that I'm using the straight
punch from the second exchange not the
last technique of that exchange so that
way it just seems like a constant stream
of energy like this non-stop sort of
action sequence even though it was like
these really tiny bursts so that way you
can keep everybody safe and you can sort
of control how you know how things are
done and then you you you you use
composition based on like what's going
to make that technique look the best so
you're able to hide their flaws and and
sort of show their strengths hi their
weaknesses that sort of thing but um but
yeah I think um that whole three weeks
of making my first feature with I had no
script I had no you know I had to write
it as we shot and they had no prep we
had no money you know that's probably
like the brokest I've been but that but
that movie got like worldwide
distribution and it's sort of yeah that
also showed me like how much power you
really have like as a content creator
like how you can sort of create
something and even if it's in a rough
situation it can it can still do great
things and it can still be received well
and yeah that just opened up a world of
possibilities after that and then how
confident did that make you going
forward before every other shoot because
you basically had the bottom fall out
yeah and you still made it work somehow
I mean you had people that it could have
been very mad they took all this time
off whatever everybody was probably like
heartbroken you made it work somehow how
does that build your confidence yeah I
mean it
it was great because um I never I never
gave them the impression that things
were just you know what I mean I was
very calm you know this happened but
this is what we're gonna do you know
like I never I never made it feel like
it was a problem
like just this thing that we couldn't
get past or you know I just I don't know
is this the way I delivered it to him I
guess and then I think also because they
had seen a lot of the other work I'd
done like the shorts and stuff like that
I think they were pretty confident that
like you know we'd be okay but I was
very much I was never like oh my god
they did this and I don't know what
we're gonna you know I never never did
that I was just like hey you know we're
gonna just change gears a little bit you
know this is what happened we're still
making a film yeah so I think just being
calm and never sort of letting on how
crazy things had gotten I think I think
that helped a lot and to have it go so
wrong and to be able to come out the
other side was something that was like
tangible like yeah that changed
everything for me like you know I just
didn't feel like it was there I didn't
feel like it was anything I couldn't do
at that point I just felt like you just
find a way like you stay calm you figure
it out you problem-solve and because if
you strip away all the essentials right
when you get down to what the film
really is its location its actors you
know lighting sound you know composition
storytelling you know and whether it's
100 million dollars or a hundred dollars
you can still tell a story
if you
have the tools and you know you can you
you can still tell a great story it's it
really isn't about the money at all um
money helps money can make things
grander or bigger or whatever but when
it really comes down to telling like a
human story it you really don't need a
lot to do that you know and uh yeah
that's what it taught I'm sure it wasn't
excellent at the time yeah that's really
scary yeah I just didn't I really didn't
panic just because I was so used to it I
was so used to making these things like
the way I was making them you know like
as a kid like I was so used to just okay
I'm gonna write in my I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know we're gonna use this room
or that room like so to me it felt like
just going back to like how I started
you know and I was comfortable in that
and I think that's the reason why I
didn't see a reason to panic I just was
like okay we can't do that but we can do
this you know yeah we were talking about
heroes a bit off camera and you would
talked about how your desire to create
or show a certain type of hero was very
important to you yeah you talk about
what that is and and what does a hero
represent to you in storytelling so yeah
my fascination with it it was with with
the hero figure it didn't start like
with with comic books and superheroes it
really started with action heroes and
martial arts and growing up as a young
kid studying Chinese martial arts I I
was a huge fan of action cinema and by
the time I reached maybe 15 is when it
really struck me I you know I realized
that all my
rules were Asian you know and I was like
wow like I'm doing the same martial arts
but none of them look like me you know
and so yeah that's really when my
journey started as far as I'm making
because I made a vow that I would create
platforms where I could showcase heroes
that look like me but I fought like that
you know and that was sort of where like
my filmmaking journey started right then
I just felt like I wanted to see more
heroes that reflected the way I looked
up there on the screen and it was it was
never like exclusively that you know
exclusively my image but I just wanted
to see I guess more but even playing
whew like more heroes that reflected
myself and my friends and so yeah that's
sort of where it came from
for me the idea of a hero like a person
who would fight for what they believed
in and fight for the right things and
protect the people they love and protect
the world and someone who was like
righteous and an upstanding and you know
who had sort of all those qualities that
I felt were like important you know
things that were instilled in me as well
and yeah so that's kind of I guess where
that started and even even up until now
I felt like I wanted to contribute to
that I wanted to contribute to the idea
of now that the superhero genre is so
big like it's sort of taken over
everything and I get a lot of
discussions now a lot of a lot of like
people focusing on like more
inclusiveness I guess across the board
and all genres and and it's interesting
now I feel like audiences are more vocal
about it and they're sort of ready to
see more representation of female
superheroes superheroes of color every
race every Creed and yeah I didn't want
to be one of those people who just sort
of complained about it I wanted to do my
part and sort of contribute to it and
that's sort of where Wonder Studios
comes from run the studios it's like a
division of my company shadow motion
pictures and that division is going to
be sort of solely for like films in a
soupy Arizona and sci-fi genre yeah what
about the character flaws and heroes
today that are acceptable or maybe even
embraced versus decades ago have we
evolved in terms of allowing these
superheroes to have more character flaws
I think so I think I think because we've
been exposed to a lot more I think I
think one back in the 90s and you know
80s 90s that sort of thing that was a
very black-and-white sort of this is
what heroes this is what the villain is
you know that sort of thing and I think
I'm because we're being we've been
exposed to so much more material through
streaming platforms through television
and movies we're getting a lot more I'm
noticing things are a lot more raw a lot
more gritty and we're sort of seeing
characters that to me feel more human
because they're they're gray you know
they're shades of grey and to me it's a
more realistic depiction of what a hero
could be
because I feel like everyone button has
shades of gray there's certain times
when things really happen in our lives
that we may get angry or but we're still
a good person but you know we may react
in a negative way or whatever the case
is and yeah I feel like social media I
feel like just media in general sort of
impacted these stories and we're seeing
a lot more anti-heroes and you know
we're seeing a lot more shades of gray
which is is much more interesting and
sort of the cardboard cut-out sort of
hero because it's harder to relate to
that idea because nobody's black and
white and nobody is perfect you know and
so I think that's why people relate to
Batman more than man I think that's why
Batman is more it's probably a little
more popular than Superman because
Superman is more of an idea than a
tangible sort of it's hard to connect on
a human level with Superman you know
because he's you know he's like a god
and he doesn't do anything wrong you
know what I mean so whereas with Batman
like all of the reasons he became a hero
was sort of born out of pain and loss
and he's angry and he's isolated and you
know all these things like people I
think relates him more yeah I like
Batman more too so I think that's what
is it those are the reasons why though
do you think as a culture we're almost
distrustful of quote-unquote heroes or
figures that are too perfect in this day
and age yeah I think we immediately
don't buy into it like if you know cuz
there's no one's perfect you know
[Music]
if we're talking about a human being
they can't be perfect so it's the minute
we're sort of presented with that idea
we're like we're looking for things that
are wrong we're looking for you know
like we're looking for the truth I guess
yeah yeah that's how I feel about I just
there is no perfect person and anyone
who presents themselves that way is not
to be trusted for sure we're in an age
now where let's let's dig up some dirt
on this person not not saying that
that's the right thing to do it almost
seems like that's where we've gone it's
become acceptable let's find an old
photo let's find an old tweet let's try
to get somebody on their dance floor and
make them look bad in public something I
mean it's become part of of what we see
every day in the news and on Twitter and
yeah absolutely
it would seep into storytelling yeah and
I think I think that's that's a
dangerous approach I think because I
like it I like in social media to like a
Sims like like a live-action Sims game
where people have sort of these lives
that they've created and they're sort of
living through these avatars and you
know I've always felt that like the
bigger social media got the more
antisocial people became like because
you rarely see people in person outside
of some type of event especially like
when it comes to the industry like
people rarely spend any time together
anymore like outside of a film event or
a premiere or some type of something
like that but just to see each other
like you're not gaining any other thing
from it other than just you know having
that relationship and spending time and
being close and that sort of thing and I
think that's been lost quite a bit
because of the way that
social media sort of operates like them
you know and that's why you have people
who are very awkward socially because
they they never they never seen anyone
they you know it's easier to sort of be
more outspoken and to have a certain
personality when it's online because
there's no physical there's no physical
connection there it's you know and I
remember growing up and all the time you
see your friends you'd have to go
outside and hang out and be outside all
day and you know you saw people every
day and that's how you built those
relationships and um and yeah now it's
very rare that that happens and so I
think even because being a writer I
think like your life experiences help
you but if you're if most of what you're
experiencing is like through the web
it's like what is you know where does it
come from now like what it is where it
is you know how much of yourself are you
really putting into your stories or you
know I think you can lose a bit of that
genuine sort of part of yourself that is
so important in storytelling like and it
becomes more of data like what you pull
from the world in which you pull from
the internet and you know maybe maybe
not so much of anything you've
experienced but just just information
what you think is going to work but it's
if it's not coming from a genuine place
then do people really connect with your
art oh no you know what I mean like I'm
not sure I know for me personally I
always try to
put something of myself like some
personal part of me in every film like I
could probably look at every movie I've
made and look at that storyline and it's
gonna be some reflection of my life some
kind of way something I went through
[Music]
yeah I'm just saying cuz even I think
cuz it William Gibson cyberpunk Roger
Lee Neuromancer and those different
books about the cyber world he says he's
actually not a technophile he's actually
the opposite and you would think that
that would not be the case since that's
what he's writing about yeah that just a
sort of the need for human connection in
terms of developing a story and you know
it is lost and maybe people gain it from
creating Berner accounts and then they
try to get reactions from people and
maybe that's they can sort of see human
emotion is pushing buttons online which
definitely there's places for that but
that's a good point in terms of being
able to go out and just connect with
people now even when you see them
there's a phone in their hand and you're
not really connecting yeah yeah you see
like you go to lunch with someone and
their heads on the phone the whole time
you know or everybody at the table
they're everybody's head is in the phone
and then they'll they'll eat and then
when they're done eating their heads are
back on the phone and it's just like
there's so much going on around you but
no one's paying attention to it you know
it's just interesting like like that's
the way people wake up the minute they
open their eyes they start reaching for
their phone you know before they can
even see clearly you know they've
already reached for their phone and then
Jon see what they missed what they
missed you know and whether it's real or
not
yeah and then I mean it's I'm afraid to
see what the futures gonna look like
they'll probably just get chips
implanted and be on line 24 hours even
when they sleep
no you know how do you craft the hero's
journey wow that's super interesting
costing I've been hmm
I think it starts with how you define
what a hero is even I think that people
think a hero is just somebody who puts
on the suit
and a cape you know what I mean and it
can be there was a concept but I started
working on a few years ago where it was
about a homeless man who like was a vet
and you know lived in the slums and he
had met this this girl she was like a
foster kid and you know she gotten my
kidnapped it we're gonna traffic her or
something like that and you had this
homeless man who nobody just paid
attention to and he she was the only
person who referred to him she would see
him every day and talk to him and give
him sandwiches and you know she was the
only friend he had you know and he like
went through all this stuff and fought
and died at the end to get this little
girl back you know I mean and and she
was but she was a kid no one cared about
you know and to me he's a hero you know
I mean like it's so I think sometimes
that the focus or the perception of a
hero is what we see in all these
superhero films but I feel like and in
really everyday situations and in any
situation you can find a person you
would consider a heroic or hero and
those stories need to be told as well so
I think that especially as filmmakers
like I don't want anyone to get
discouraged like
as far as if they feel like they can't
make a film like Superman or this big
sort of superhero film you can still
make films about heroes you know like
and everyday walks of life like it
doesn't have to be just the status quo
example of what a hero is it can be any
scenario any situation like a dog can be
a hero you know yeah I think there's
there's so many ways to approach that
idea and I always but I always try to go
with what we may not have seen before
like I always try to find something they
always say like there's no original
story you know that sort of thing but I
think the approach can be original or
the way that you attack the material can
be an original way you know I don't know
if that answered the question but I just
you know you said earlier about being
very visual and how you were gonna write
out your you know the different action
sequences so are you good at writing
them or are you better with sort of the
conception of it like in your head and
then just because you're kind of
speaking your own language to yourself
because you're gonna also be behind the
camera yeah you know what to do or would
you say if someone else got ahold of one
of your scripts they would know exactly
how to do that action um they would know
early on like when I ate when I used to
write scripts early on I would actually
write out I found this to be the wrong
approach very quickly but I would write
out all of the action in the script
the script would end up being 300 pages
you know and so what I started doing is
I would just write if there's an action
scene I would set it up and sort of
write action sequence one and then
separate all the information and like a
separate you know separate writing or
separate information so I would just put
that annotation there and then I would
expand upon it like separately so that
the the actors when they're reading it
they don't they're not understanding all
that stuff so yeah I started to split
the two apart and I used to do it the
hard way like I would write out every
single technique almost like I'm you
know playing cards or something I would
write the name of the character
side-by-side and then if this person
does this technique this person does
that this first it does this this person
does that and I would write out every
single technique and after a while I
stopped doing that and so now I just get
together with like on my team and we'll
we'll actually corrigan the action and
we use what's called our blocking tapes
like we would shoot the action and sort
of a more primitive setting and then on
set we just use those tapes that we shot
you know we've already worked out the
composition and we've already worked out
all the camera angles and all the
choreography and and then we use that as
a template or God when we're on set we
we sort of go about that I found that to
be like the most effective way and and
also just having time with the actors
sort of with this stuff man with the
actors being able to sort of prep them
and get them is as prepared as possible
and seeing what their strengths are if
you have actors who may not have any
training but they may be
I've done a lot of sports or they might
be flexible or agile or you know have
good coordination you kind of see what
works for them and you sort of base it
around what they're what they got out
like what their strengths are but yeah
it's it's involved with it over time
like um the way I sort of approach
action and when I when I was really
young when I first started out I didn't
do any of that I just I would
choreograph the fight sequences the day
of the shoot and do it that way
shoot choreograph and just sort of shoot
it in sections yeah but now we have like
a much better system in place you know
give better results have you ever done
it where you sort of reverse engineer at
you you take you watch the film and you
like let's say the raid two or something
and then you're documenting all the
moves that they're making or no you've
never kind of tried to reverse engineer
and other directors sort of notes as far
as action no like but what I do i do
love it's like special features like i
love special features more than the film
because i like to see how everything's
done so i I will like if I see a really
great shot or something like that
I do I will reverse engineer how that
shot was done or how yeah but as far as
action not specifically but but yeah I
think I think anything technical as far
as composition or lighting or any unique
shot or anything like that I like to see
how those things are done and then sort
of be like okay how can I get that same
result but justwe ag4 then then what
they might have done it for so yeah yeah
special features is a gift to any movie
lover
yeah especially if they're older ones I
watched one Brian De Palma and on Carrie
and then it was great it was just
fantastic you know and yeah just to hear
to that she wasn't the original choice
which I can't imagine anyone else but
Spacek but yeah just to see all
that and it's just really like a it's
like a present all right yeah I always
feel like you know whoever that role is
forward that's the person in most cases
I mean you know that's who it gets you
know like it may not be who you think in
the beginning but when I think back to
so many movies that had cast a certain
people like um you know Will Smith
rejecting the role of neo and then
calories getting it I can't imagine
anybody but Keanu in that role you know
who are your top five action directors
and which works of their own I would
have to say and and and this probably
explains a lot of the way that I
approach film as well like Wilson yep
who was a famous Hong Kong director
David Fincher for sure Christopher Nolan
Zack Snyder and probably a yuen woo-ping
like as far as action goes yeah I think
I think the for Christopher Nolan is
like his his scale and how epic his
homes are for David Fincher I think the
meticulousness and the attention to
detail he puts into his projects Zack
Snyder for like his visual aesthetic I
still think like Watchmen is like one of
the most technically beautiful films
I've ever seen like as far as
composition lighting you know it's it's
a gorgeous home
yuen woo-ping is a legend you know as
far as in the action in the action world
as far as being that one of the greatest
choreographers who ever lived and was
the other dog man amazing ah Wilson yeah
Wilson is also he sort of changed the
face of Hong Kong action films Wilson
yep is the director who did the hip
modern films with Donnie Yen and dragon
Tiger gate and and what else it was in
there yeah an SPL which is one of my
favourite films and yeah he did the way
that they sort of approached filmmaking
Hong Kong at that time his style was so
bold and different like it really just
was uniquely its own thing you know so
yeah those directors I think have
probably had the biggest influence on me
as far as the way I approach filmmaking
like my style and the meticulousness and
you know that sort of thing
like um always trying to make every
project look uniquely its own like it
nothing looks like no one looks like the
other I'm sort of a big fan of that like
having everything sort of have its own
stamp and its own look and its own feel
I don't like to repeat things I've done
not only like even if it comes to just a
look of it I just I don't like to
projects to look the same you know say
yeah I think those that it those are
definitely my top top five right there
what about remakes I realize that
doesn't mean that they'll necessarily
look the same but does that bother you
or you actually enjoy some of the
remakes oh wow it depends cuz it's a lot
of times it's
I tend to like the originals more I
think I think a lot of times stuff gets
lost in the translation like though
there are certain things that made that
from popular that they're trying to draw
from but it's it's it's never really the
same and in most cases you lose a lot
more so I think with the storytelling
then the production of it like sometimes
you can have something that's produced
even a little sharper but the
storytelling is where people seem to not
focus on too much it's more of just sort
of the overall theme of it but yeah I
feel like a magic gets lost a lot with
with remakes you know I'm not I'm not
opposed to him but um in most cases I
don't think there is good is original
mm-hm you think it's because we again
like we rely too much on the tools that
are going to make it look so highly
produced but then yeah I think it's a
lot of times it's um truth be told in a
lot of cases a cash grab like it's sort
of cashing in on the name of it that
thing or you know because it was popular
and not really focusing more on why it
was popular like what about this mixture
of things resonated with people not just
the name of it but what about is
specifically resonated and I think
that's that's the question and I think
you know in a lot of cases if if you
can't add anything more to that then I
think it should be left alone where do
you struggle most with writing
screenplays interestingly enough it's
just writing I think I've been writing
for so long
that I'm at the point now where I wish
there was some really good software
where I could just talk and it would
just write it in script format for me
you know the physical act of getting it
out of your head I think is the hardest
part now because it's usually most most
creatives especially a few storytellers
there's never a time when you don't have
stories just constantly coming into your
head like ideas and you know and even if
you flush out the idea fully when it's
just a physical act of typing you know I
think that's the thing when I was really
young it was fun you know just young and
you just type in and everything's great
and you can just type for hours and
hours every day and you know but because
I do so many other things I think that
now I just I would just really love to
just have that be automated you know I
gotta I'm you know I'm getting to the
place now where I have a few younger
writers that I'm working with where I
can sort of outline the story not for
everything you know there's certain
films that I'm like okay this is just my
baby right here but certain projects
where I'll do an outline and then I'll
send it to them and then they can write
the script based on my outline and then
send it back and then I'll just like
punch it up you know so that's been
that's been pretty cool lately but but
yeah I'm just trying to I'm waiting on
that magic thing where I don't have to
type anymore you know what about writing
in long form is that going to or no you
know it's cool cuz like when I like when
I started out I started on the old
school type
like with the big keys that come out and
you know - you know like I started
that's how I started and then moved to
like the electric typewriter and then
the computer but um but yeah I just
think um I just I just want to talk I
just want to talk and have something
just typed for me I if I could never
physically type another script again I'd
be great that'd just be awesome is that
because you don't like the the
screenplay format you know you'd rather
do it almost a novel form and then I
just think it's just the the physical
act of like that because it takes so
much brainpower to write it's very like
exhausting like it it it uh and just
like it just takes your soul you know
like so I think it's just that part of
it like I love I love telling stories
and I still have a lot of things I want
to say but I think because of the fact
that I I still edit I still shoot I
still direct I still do sound designer
certain products I still do you know
like because I'm doing all that other
stuff you know when I want to physically
have to type a script like I might get a
couple pages and I'm done my you know I
have to really be like unless I'm mom
you know you're so in it and you're
trying to just get it out of your head
you know that's different but uh I try
to set goals though like because because
uh I'm older now says it's harder to
write as much as I did before so I try
to set goals like a certain amount of
pages or that sort of thing like um it's
hard to do it that way you know just
break it into sections
[Music]
you know right now I'm writing a
finishing up the almighty street team
I'm finishing that adapting those comic
books and toast script and I've probably
got 30 pages left like I'm almost there
but but yeah it's been a process of and
that's been difficult to like adapting
something that already exists like a
comic book or doing an adaptation it's
very different than when you started
coming up with something completely
original it's sort of riding that line
of how much do you keep how much do you
change sort of bringing it from a comic
book into live-action there's certain
things that are going to operate
differently so that's been a unique
challenge this is the first time I've
done that adapted anything that it was
pre-existing so that's been like a a
unique challenge like an interesting one
but but very different because I want to
stay true to the spirit in of the
material and then there's a great
moments in the material that you
definitely want in there and then
certain places you have to sort of
expand it to make it work but I think I
found a really good space with it you
know does it ever frustrate you that it
takes so long to make the kind of movies
you want to make oh yeah absolutely by
nature I think the industry just moves
very slowly and so on everything is a
process and there's so much you don't
control there's so much that's sort of
out of your hands and so yeah it's um
[Music]
sometimes it can be frustrating to
hurry-up-and-wait
mentality or
waiting for certain people to get
certain things done and then also like
with with yourself you know there's only
so much you can do in a day you know you
um you don't want to get so obsessed
with things that you don't that you
neglect your life you neglect your
family and things like that you want to
have balance which is really tough
because you know most of us in industry
is so driven like you know we know
things move like at a certain pace and
if we move at if we're slow and
everything else too slow then nothing's
gonna happen so you tend to push harder
to sort of compensate compensate for how
slow things actually move so on but it's
important it took me a while to find
that balance like I I was a person who
was 17 hours a day um you know only
sleep three hours a night you know a
sort of thing and so driven and after so
many years of it you realize like it's
not helping that much like you're giving
so much of yourself and your time and
you're neglecting your family and you're
like as soon as I get this film done
I'll be able to say hi to you you that
sort of thing and then when that's done
now you're doing something else and you
know so you got to find a balance and
you have to have tremendous patience
like you can't be a person who is
reactionary and and who gets frazzled
very easily you really have to have a
lot of focus and you have to be super
patient and just try to look at the big
picture but also look at just day by day
like what can I do today
to sort of move things forward and just
have like these smaller goals and he's
smaller levels that you can sort of
reach and these goals you can hit every
day to sort of continue to push towards
what you what you want and eventually
you'll get there like you know some
projects takes take years to finish and
I always say like it's it's what you do
when no one's watching that really
counts you know yeah what about the
balance in terms of how people receive
the project you know there's that sort
of artist cliche saying that the work is
never really yours once it's finished ya
know if you subscribe to that but um no
I mean I there are gonna be people who
connect with your work you know and
there are gonna be people who may not
and that's fine you know to me and you
for me as long as I feel like I've done
like by the time that project goes out
as long as I feel like I did everything
I could to make that project the best it
could be
i I'm good with it you know I can live
with it you have to sort of move on
nothing's ever perfect there's always
gonna be those things like man if I just
could have reshot this or if I had more
time or money or but I think is the
hardest like that's just natural like we
all do that like we all are
perfectionist and but yeah you have to
sort of be ok with with just doing the
best you can with that art and and just
letting it live and and you know the
people who are gonna respond to it they
will but you know some
I never really I never kind of I never
focus on that
I never focus on what how is it gonna go
like it you know it's gonna sort of live
and be what it is and if if within
myself I know I did the best I could
with it I poured everything I had into
it and I wanted to make it as great as I
could
I'm good or with it you know and so far
it's really cool like I've done pretty
good like I've gotten the Energy's been
good with you know the kind of films
that make yeah I'm happy with the word
where the fanbase is right now you know
with my material you know but everything
I do I do for the people watching like I
really want to give them like the best
experience they can with that piece of
piece of art and entertain them as much
as I can and I always want to put more
value into it then the some of the
resources I had at the time you know if
I have $150,000 and I make a project I
want to look like I spent half a million
dollars or a million dollars you know
that sort of thing so I'm always sort of
pushing as far as I can with the
production value with you know sound
composition lighting actors like
everything you know
I've heard you say composition I've
heard you talk about composition many
times do you just even go like to the
grocery store and you're just like okay
this aisle at Ralph's I'm framing it
here I would do this yeah that was
always a a really big thing for me I
would notice the way things are framed
and like what I deemed is cinematic you
know what I mean and I always felt like
that was one of the weapons that like a
person who is an independent filmmaker
or a content creator versus money I
always felt like that was one of those
tools that could help make your project
better like the way it's lit the way it
sounds and the way that you compose your
shots you know like the term cinematic
like how cinematic can you be even if
you have no money how can we make this
look like a movie like how could we make
this look big how can we make this look
bring as much spectacle to it as you can
even if you don't have very much you
know and yeah so yeah I'm like huge on
composition like I'll be that's the
first thing I noticed when I'm watching
something you know you know look at the
composition and look at the way these
actors are framed like why are they
frame this way what are they trying to
say like what you know like yeah I just
dissect movies a lot and even when I
don't want to but even it sounds like in
real and non movie life you're still
dissecting yeah yeah you know I just I
see
cinema and everything like I see art and
everything I see cinema and everything
like I can't turn it off you know it's
such a big part of me and yeah it's it's
one of those things like that just this
yeah it just lives in you like you know
and yeah I see so many shots right now
just you know just the way light hits a
person's face and the way the sunlight
comes in creeps into a room like you're
always thinking who those things you're
always noticing those things
of all the films you've made can you
think back to some of the biggest
mistakes with some of the action
sequences I think I think the way I used
to shoot action because I sort of
changed my approach later on like when I
when I first started out because I grew
up on Hong Kong action cinema I would
approach shooting an action scene the
way they do in Hong Kong you know so
they have a very particular style in a
way that they like approach shooting
action and then so you kind of you kind
of see that as like the eastern way of
doing it right and then I would look at
western films and how they would shoot
action and it was very different they in
the West it's more they see action more
for coverage and then the East the shops
are designed specifically for the
technique that's being used at the time
and so later on I you know I was
shooting the way they did in the East
and then I was like well there's a film
at that ah call me King right and I said
well this is very much a Western film
and I just don't feel like the eastern
approach fits now you know with this
particular film and so I I ended up sort
of marrying the two like the way that
Eastern films a shot in the way western
films are shot so I used Eastern
choreography or Hong Kong style
choreography but I shot it in a Western
away so that was where I sort of married
the two ideologies and and found that it
was like really affect it was like oh
this is really dope like this is this is
better you know to me so yeah I stopped
shooting the eastern way and I started
just keeping the choreography or the in
of the East in terms of choreography but
shooting it in a more western way and it
just felt more modern that way so yeah I
think that was the biggest lesson I
think um over the years like have been
shot and choreographed probably upwards
to 300 fight scenes at this point I
found that that was the most effective
way to kind of give it a fresh a fresh
approach like that
the choreography was fresh but the the
the eastern way of shooting it was just
a little over the top I guess like a
little too much you know
so yeah shooting more like a shooting
action more like a western
cinematographer but using that Eastern
fight techniques I found like a really
nice fusion and then I've sort of been
doing that ever since
yeah in speaking of call me King got a
distribution deal and was on Netflix
mm-hmm he talked about so yeah we it
actually started out as a web series
before I got funded it was a web series
called to eewan which was like patois
like Haitian language for a kill point
and so I did I did like nine episodes of
it found like a great audience for it
and yeah it just garnered a lot of
energy I was like on a lot of vlogs and
different things like that and I kind of
set it up the way it was like an HBO
type of show like I set it up like every
Tuesday at 1:00 you know and I had a new
episode coming out and all these blogs
would do like reviews on each episode it
was a really cool it was it was actually
the first web series I'd ever made and
so I there were some advantages some
things I liked about it but there were
some disadvantages
because it was short and I felt like
there was more story I wanted to tell
but it was the format was so short I
couldn't really say as much as I wanted
and so myself and my partner did Tom on
that project aim and Joseph we decided
to do a feature feature film version of
it and so on yeah we did a feature film
and ended up getting a limited
theatrical release through AMC Theaters
and I went to Netflix and PlayStation
Xbox sky like all these different
platforms and we there was a scene
something really cool happened with it
too there was a scene in the beginning
of the film that went viral like
somebody took took took just took a
video of the scene and posted it online
and it was this girl asking this guy
like to tell the truth in their
relationship like yo like stop wanna me
just tell the truth and then he just it
was this monologue where he just tore to
pieces and totally truthing
and somehow it just found its way online
and it gone in like 7 million views like
on this one scene it was hotly like
debated and people were like yeah you
tell her and the women were furious and
it just became like this thing and what
was cool is like everybody kept going
well what is what is this from well you
know and everybody go oh this is call me
King on Netflix this was call me King on
that flick like this call me you know
and so that's how it ended up pushing
like comic King to over like 100 million
streams like on Netflix is because like
this just a scene that went viral and
people kept asking what it was so yeah
that was really cool that was like that
film was really close about these
Haitian Gun Runners and
they could speak like five languages and
yeah it was it was really close really
well-received you know which platform
has had the biggest impact on your
career
I always said Netflix for sure
definitely the two audience you can
reach like and I know it's weird to say
because I've had theatrical releases as
well but because it's such a huge global
audience I think yeah I think Netflix is
amazing the the reach they have is
pretty it's pretty extraordinary what
they've built and so on and nowadays I
in certain instances I prefer like
Netflix over at the article run like
depending on the cities and like -
probably the amount of marketing put
behind it but yeah i think i think
theaters and netflix are very close
right now but yeah I'd say I said
Netflix for sure are there are certain
cities that are surprisingly
surprisingly well-received your films
that most people would think oh I
wouldn't expect that to be a big market
huh I actually had a theatrical release
in Korea with call me King actually yeah
we're in theaters in Korea we're in
theaters in Africa and in North America
and yeah I had some friends some Korean
friends who called me on the way to the
theater like hey we're going to see you
move you know and I thought I was a
really cool man because I'm a huge fan
of Korean cinema I think the amazing
storytellers and so yeah I think the
Korean market South Korean market
specifically it's been interesting to
see like the reaction it's had there so
that was a thousand unique
place South America very much so and
then North America but also Korea like
has been I think Korean is very the most
interesting yeah
when call me King was on Netflix did you
see a lot of people reaching out to on
social media emails yeah absolutely and
what was interesting too is a lot of the
actors in the film they got a lot of
energy from fans of the movie like
rather be in in person or online yeah a
lot of us got a lot of I got quite a few
jobs from it but uh but yeah a lot of
people sort of reaching out and finding
the film it trended for a long time on
on Netflix it was really cool but I
think a lot of that had to do with the
the viral scene from it but yeah I think
there was a there was a big sort of
influx of people reaching out who saw
the film industry people as well yeah I
think I think up to that point that had
been like my biggest film up to that
point as far as reach and I think what
it did the reaction it got from the
industry for sure so were there other
films that you did that where you
expected it to go the way call me King
did because it was a so people say like
you can't orchestrate anything viral and
and there's so many times when you think
something's gonna be huge and it's not
and then vice versa because of the
relationship aspect of that one scene
and people debating and then they go hey
I need to see this I want to know who
the filmmaker is yeah well I mean comic
King was the last film I did before
Lazarus so a Lazarus isn't out yet but
like the anticipation of it is
hi like you know I've already gotten
like a lot of jobs just on the trailer a
lot of meetings things are looking
really good as far as like we have a lot
of options as far as distribution and so
yeah there's a desert there's already
sort of started to be like groundswell
you know we haven't put out the trailer
yet but we will
pretty soon the movie is going to come
out this summer and yeah I'm expecting
some some good results from it most
definitely yeah when people wrote to
about call me King what were they
writing to about like what were they did
they have questions they just want to
praise you there were quite a few
accolades but also people were just
happy to see it sort of exists in the
action kromm's onra like similar to like
Goodfellas or the Godfather sort of in
that space but it was the first time
people had seen like this type of
approach like I was saying earlier with
being Haitian with them being gun
runner's but they but they were very
refined you know they spoke different
languages they they wore suits and they
spoke very eloquently they there was a
really cool scene in the film where one
of our lead characters or he's talking
to his brother but he's sort of telling
him how bourbon is made you know how it
actually it's clear when it starts and
then the reason it turns brown is
because it's curated is cured in wooden
barrels and so the wood is what gives
the bourbon its colour like it changes
colour from clear to to this this brown
color because of the way it's it's made
and so he was using it as as an an
analogy and how like if you leave it too
long it'll lose integrity and so he was
he's sort of breaking down this this I
these ideals to him but he's using
bourbon as a way to do it so people were
like really they were like wow like
that's different you know like we
haven't seen that yet like you know the
you know they're not drug dealers at Gun
Runners so I just wanted to sort of
create something in the crime genre but
do it in it in a way that may represent
like characters we haven't seen in this
genre before like and do it in a more a
more unique approach then I guess we may
have seen from a lot of films that when
you see people of color in those films
in that genre you you you expect it to
be a lot more hood I guess a street and
not as a refined and so I wanted to sort
of challenge that idea and so I think I
think some people found it to be like
really interesting I'm wondering if you
can tell us the story of how you're
finishing up or you've already finished
with call me King and then you start
writing Lazarus or how do you how are
you pitching this to investors yeah I
guess I had the idea for Lazarus as I
was finishing call me King actually and
I already started started talking to
actor Sean Riggs and he's someone I've
known for a long time so I knew you know
I knew we had planned on sort of
producing something together but I
wasn't sure what it was up until around
that time when call me King was sort of
coming out and
it was actually a pretty easy process to
get funded just based on what we'd
already done and you know the definitely
the success of call me King it made it
pretty easy it's probably the easiest of
gotten of a project funded because you
know we still had a lot of energy from
it and actually the investor of Lazarus
had seen call me King you know so yeah
it was it happened pretty quickly
actually like um I had the story the
concept in mind but I hadn't written it
yet and you know once when Scotty King
was done and sort of made it made it
sort of its rounds I kind of quickly
moved into lasers and yeah we were up
and running pretty quickly actually yeah
and and all that stuff was sort of
coming together like the idea of
creating a universe I knew that I needed
the first hero in that universe I wanted
to come from me and then I wanted to
start to bring in other concepts from
other independent like comic book
creators and stuff like that and so yeah
yeah I came together pretty pretty fast
actually yeah you're writing the script
yeah yeah so so yeah I had the idea I
sort of took the same approach didn't
outline and just started writing and it
took me probably a few months actually
to finish a script but as I was
finishing it you know we were already
getting funding and sort of getting
ready yeah we it got funded kind of just
off the idea of it you know the idea of
it and then
call me King was like okay you know did
you approach the investors or did they
approach you yeah we approach them you
know it was interesting because I'm some
of the discussions that came from call
me King was like hey if you guys are
doing you know something else like you
know whatever you're doing that's like
we you know we'd love to talk about it
or let me know you know what's going on
after that so yeah as soon as we had
sort of decided to move forward Lazarus
like once I had the idea sort of fleshed
out like we went to certain people and
like hey this is what we're doing next
do you know what I mean and so yeah they
they got on board you know pretty
quickly
what's the idea for the film what were
you pitching them that was just the idea
like how did you go in and present it I
had a bit of like concept art and I had
this sort of the I'd done sort of like a
detailed synopsis on the film so I was
able to sort of break down the story and
how everything sort of played out I had
a had a ballpark of what it would take
to make the film and the fact that it
was in the superior John uhrin
you know that was like super appealing
to people especially with how popular
dijanna had become by then so I think
that was one of the biggest things that
intrigued him was like sort of my idea
and my approach to it but the fact that
it was a superhero and a hero of color
as well and and it sort of lived to be
in that space so I call it a superhero
thriller because it's it does have like
some horror undertone you know and and
so yeah I think that those were the
things that really
sold the idea of it was the genre if I
if I was making maybe another gangster
film or something maybe it would have
took a little more nothing maybe maybe
not I don't know but but the fact that
it was in the superhero genre like
people got really excited about and what
what's the film about oh I'm trying to
give too much away essentially it's a a
city is it's like a it's called Paradise
City is a city that's sort of like in
the heart of like a Chicago or like a LA
and this whole city is sort of overrun
by crime and it's a bad place you know
and there's a synthetic drug that's you
you burn it and you sort of the crystals
produces red smoke and you inhale it and
it it's like my notes ring and so you
know the whole infrastructure of the
city is sort of based upon that and the
people who who operated and they use a
lot of people in the city as runners you
know they recruit a lot of people to to
work for them and so our main character
ray Lazarus like he was like a military
that he was a sort of a bad person
before he went to the military and then
he saw a lot of things and grew up and
became a better person so when he came
back he I was a totally different human
being and um got a lot of his friends to
go legit and change their lives and you
know to like a very productive citizen
and they tried to recruit him he said no
something very bad happens to him that
sort of sends him on this journey to
undo like a lot of what's going on in
the city but in that moment where he's
well this bad thing happens to him he's
approached by an entity and this entity
sends him on this course but it has its
own agenda you know I mean that's kind
of all I could say really I probably
said too much but but yeah it's but he's
he's like this super-powered being that
is trying to free like this city from
the people that have sort of enslaved
the city through this this synthetic
drug are you able to talk about one of
the biggest financial risks you've taken
with one of your projects I think it's I
know a lot of people talk about maxing
out like credit cards and stuff like
that that's actually not a good idea
yeah it's not a good idea if you can
help it I mean you want to invest in
yourself but you want to also be super
careful about the kind of debt you put
yourself in and if that particular
project at that time is worth that
amount of debt you know maybe there's
something else you can do in the
meantime something different you know if
you have a family especially you know
and you know I have a wife I named
Isabel Scott she's has her own YouTube
channel directors wife and she talks
about like stuff in the industry and
interviews people and stuff like that so
but yeah having a family you got to be
super careful like about you know the
approach you take to making films and
like the kind of investments you know
you make so I would say yeah there was a
project I produced on my own like it
worked out but yeah I kind of maxed out
like like I can't you know I can't get
credit cards anymore because we like you
know maxed out these cards I'm still
like paying high stuff well yeah but
yeah I would just say that like if if
there's another way you know maybe not
do that
you know maybe not max out the credit
cards you know or someone else's credit
card don't max that don't do that
how much martial arts training do your
actors have to have well ultimately they
don't have to have any it helps but if
they don't have any you know any other
types of skills physical skills also
help like if they have good coordination
if they're dancers or if the ballet
basketball you know any type of anything
physical helps you know but ultimately
it's it's just sort of finding like
where their strengths are physically and
sort of hiding any any other weaknesses
like if you have a person who's really
coordinated with the hands but they have
like two left feet you wouldn't give
them any kicking to do or anything like
that you know you just sort of figure
out you know what what what they can be
good at and sort of highlight that thing
but uh but ya know you don't necessarily
need any training out but I would say to
all actors you should if at some point
in your career you you're gonna be asked
to like slap someone or throw a punch
you know like so I think it's good to
take classes to try and learn some at
least basic combat skills because at
some point you may have an opportunity
and you may lose that opportunity if
you're not equipped to to handle it so I
think every actor should take some sort
of classes and sort of get some sort of
training so that they're more
comfortable being physical on-screen
yeah how do you teach them to fight
there's sort of different approaches he
can take like some of it is like real
actual martial arts technique practical
techniques some of it is more so for
stage combat or choreography before you
can really teach choreography you have
to teach them the basics of movement you
know and then there's another element of
the acting that's sort of put on top of
it so you have the physicality and then
you have the acting that you have to do
as well so yeah usually the way I
approach training an actor is I start
with real martial arts techniques like I
start with the basics
basic striking basic blocking basic
kicking stretching sort of getting them
used to very small movement you know
because I'm on screen in a fight you
want to look explosive you want to look
confident you don't want to look like
you don't know what you're doing you
want to look like you've been down in
for a long time and you're confident in
the way you move so before you get to
the choreography it really starts with
basic foundation of martial arts
technique and then you just sort of
build from there
what do you find to be the toughest part
of making a film and what makes it so
tough honestly I think post-production
you know even more so than being on set
I think post is the hardest because
that's where you really make the film
like when you're on set you're sort of
and you're filming you're getting the
ingredients to make a film but you don't
really make the film until you're in
post and there's so many steps to
sort of completing a film and getting it
ready to go out and I think the easiest
part of post is the editing for me I
think going on when you get into like
sound design and sort of mixing and
mastering and getting a dialogue cleaned
and I think that's the most laborious
part of it for me for sure is sound
design because there's there's so many
little things like that absolutely must
be there if if somebody takes one step
if somebody puts down a fork if you know
every little thing that you sort of you
know in a movie like in life you don't
pay attention to but in a film if
somebody sits a fork down and you don't
hear anything you you know there's an
alarm that goes off and so yeah I think
I think those parts of posts are the
most difficult part of the process just
really fine-tuning and ultimately
deciding what the film is going to be a
lot of times in the editing room you you
can tell the story a completely
different way you know you usually what
you had on paper and what you end up
with is very different or they're
similar we're different and so you have
to then sort of let that go let the
script go and focus more on what you
have in front of you like how do I tell
the best story with what I have in front
of me you know what I'm shot
and yeah I think post is where it it all
sort of you really get down to business
as far as what the film's going to be at
the end of the day you know so just like
that the most difficult part
so many people that come to LA so many
people they leave to LA both on a daily
basis for whatever reason you came to LA
in 2009 which is very tough time for a
lot of people most people in this
country probably in the globe what would
you advise the people when they come
here like know someone have a plan don't
have a plan keep your mind open I would
definitely say have a plan I think if
you if you're gonna come here I think
you should know someone I think it's a
much easier to sort of navigate and get
used to this city and how things work if
you if you know a few people or if you
know one person who can help get you
acclimated to it you should definitely
have a plan and you should also sort of
as much as you can talk to people and
get a good understanding of how things
work usually a lot of times as artists
you know you come to LA and you have
this idea of like oh it's gonna be this
and I'm gonna do that and and that may
not be the case at all it could be
completely different than what you think
so you want to talk to people who've
been here a while even even if you're
thinking about moving and you haven't
yet start reaching out to people in the
industry that are here like hey you know
how is it out there like how does this
work how does you know that work what
are some of the resources if they're
actors like what acting classes are you
going to like find out about central
casting find out about like breakdown
Express la casting like different sites
and like find out like where you can
sort of begin to get in get your hands
in things and get involved and
but-but-but be realistic about it be
very take a very wide eyed realistic
approach to how you can begin to sort of
build yourself up out of here and yeah I
think that's that's the main advice I
would say knowledge information real
information you know there's a I used to
say that I had goals and not dreams
because I felt like dreams was something
dream is something you have when you're
asleep but it never manifests itself in
physical reality but a goal is tangible
it's a goal is real and it's obtainable
it's it's it's a realistic thing you can
attain and continue to build on you know
so have like very realistic goals and
[Music]
small goals like don't don't start out
sort of with your head in the clouds
like really start at the bottom like
really be like okay I know I want to get
there but I know there are things I can
do there are victories I can have that I
could continue to build upon
you know also one of the most important
things you can do is really study your
craft like calling your skills so that
when you do have those opportunities
you're ready for them and and also being
able to show value and what you have to
offer like that's really important so
that it's not it's not so much of like
oh I just I want to be a star and I want
to be rich but like what do you have to
offer a producer what do you have to
offer a casting agent or a film you know
that sort of thing like so really study
and really focus on your ability to
deliver and you know if you do that
you'll get more and more opportunities
to showcase that you know because people
will see
the value and your work and they'll see
the value and what you have to offer you
know so sometimes it really starts there
instead of sort of looking outward to
agents and other people to sort of make
you into this big thing like they really
start inward and with your own craft and
what you invest in yourself and your
ability to deliver and yeah what about
them
trusting people that's a tough one
honestly that's a tough way because a
lot of people will say a lot of things
and I do personally like I personally
try not to have a pessimistic approach
to things but I'm very I'm optimistic
but I'm cautious and it says that until
something happens it doesn't exist you
know that's sort of how I look at it
like there'll be times I'll get a job
offer and they'll be like hey you know
we want to fly you to Canada and direct
this film and Rob LA and I'm like okay
that sounds cool but once I've done that
I sort of I sort of put it in another
section of my brain you know when you
hear these things it's cool but you
don't want to start like making all
these plans and sort of having all these
ideas based off of just a conversation
you know you want to wade in and sort of
be like okay I'm cautiously optimistic
but I'm gonna wait and see things play
out and it's better to sort of approach
things from that perspective if you you
don't want to you don't want to be
constantly pulled in a million
directions and then things don't work
out because the truth is like it's hard
to get these projects made like a lot of
stuff falls through the cracks a lot of
stuff doesn't work out and
you know you want to invest your time
and your energy where you feel like it's
it's gonna pay off and it's going to be
worth worth your while so I would just
say be cautiously optimistic but don't
believe anything until it's solidified
it's and it's in front of you it's
happening yeah just like protect your
your heart protect your mind you know
because you have too much disappointment
and you can start to become very
pessimistic and you know you start to
feel jaded and cynical
you know you begin to begin to hate and
the thing that you love you don't want
you don't want to allow anyone to take
that from you you know take your love of
this industry or what we do like to take
that from you you know so you have to
protect that yeah what about keeping
yourself in line not getting sidetracked
for why you came out here yeah I think
um I think time is the thing that sort
of uh determines who's really serious
about this and who's not like who's the
terms like built for it like who's built
for this it's not go for it I think over
time if you still have you know let's
say you've been doing this three four or
five years maybe some things have worked
some things are not a lot of projects
that come your way and they may have
been really made not or whatever the
case is and I think it's ultimately if
you still have the same love for it you
know like if it's in your bones and you
can't shake it
and then Tom will tell you like Tom Tom
is really going to be the thing that
shows you who you are and when it comes
to this this industry and if it really
is for you you know or if it's just
something that maybe you're in a new
place maybe you change or evolve and you
feel differently bothered but I think as
long as you love it you should do it and
if you get to the point where you hate
it and you shouldn't you know 15 to 15
years old and it has not changed like to
this day I knew then and I still know
now and it's never it's never changed
it's it's been constant I love it just
as much if not more today because I see
more possibility than I saw when I was a
kid you know what I mean so yeah I would
say I was a little bit more now because
even in even in things I've done it I
still see so much more to do and so many
more stories to tell and but I just feel
stronger now like I feel like I know
more I've been doing more more
information more knowledge and you know
what are your five tips for getting a
movie made first off be realistic don't
ask for two million dollars if you've
never made a film Oh chances are you're
not gonna get that funded so yeah I
would say firstly be realistic about
where you are about what you're doing
[Music]
create a situation where an investor
can't say no meaning have have a track
record of work I truthfully I truly feel
like if you've never made a project you
should not be asking for funding I feel
like you should do it yourself in the
beginning I think you need to produce
some things yourself because you need to
to show a person why they should invest
in you I think it's hard to get people
to just give you money it's like saying
to someone hey I want to do heart
surgery on you I've never done it before
but I just swear to god I'm gonna it's
gonna be the most amazing surgery you've
ever had it's like it's hard to convince
someone to take that kind of risk when
the you haven't shown that you're
capable of following through and I see
that a lot with a lot of young
filmmakers they're asking for money
right out the gate like yo 2 million
dollars my first movie and I'm just like
bro you're not gonna get that you know
it's gonna give you that like um so I
would say bring bring bring a lot more
value than you're asking for meaning if
if you have to show makers if one has
say never done a project before but he
has a script and a good story and an
idea and he's asking for a million
dollars and then you have another
director who has done for future films
and he's asking for $100,000
the chances are likelihood of the guy
who's only asking for very little versus
what he's already shown and that he can
accomplish there's a there's a larger
chance you're gonna get where you're
asking for and so on you know in the
beginning you want to set like a a more
modest more realistic budget like
something that you feel an investor
could part with but give them incentives
give them a reason to believe that you
can actually do this thing that you're
saying you can do and a lot of that
comes from making the sacrifices early
on and investing in yourself and making
some things like it doesn't even have to
be features it could be shorts but just
making things that you can show to
someone and say hey like I can do this
like this is this is what I have to
offer and if it's if it's technically
not good enough do it again do it again
like don't don't always be in such a
rush to ask for funding until you feel
like you're in a position where you
really have something to offer that is
worth a person parting with money even
if it's five grand 10 grand whatever
you're asking for it may not seem like a
lot but it's a lot to them you know it's
a it's a it's a risk it's an investment
so be realistic don't ask for the moon
you know start off very small produce a
few things before you get to that point
of asking so that you have examples of
your work and also have a plan like okay
you're gonna make this show what are you
gonna do with it when it's done what are
your plans like how do you plan to
distribute it how do you plan to repay
that investment how you know you and
there's so many avenues now
with aggregation sites with sites like
iTunes I think even YouTube does this
thing now where you can put your film
for sale on YouTube now and have a
certain amount but but having a have a
plan like I have a not just to make the
thing but how are you going to get this
thing to the rest of the world have a
solid plan so I think those would be my
my tips yeah you talked about being
realistic and I like that especially
here I think that's that's something a
lot of people don't always do has anyone
ever said you know you got a really high
hype to sup more because I see you being
very level about everything and then you
look at your work and it's amazing and
you're not here sort of bragging and I
see a lot of that in this town has
anyone ever said I need you to really
hype hype yourself up and and and you
just kind of want to keep it more yeah
I've heard that a lot and the truth is
like I win every time because I don't
you know like if it's harder to pay back
a million dollars than it is to pay back
three hundred fifty thousand dollars or
whatever the case is and a lot of times
to be truthful when it comes to
distribution a lot of times depending on
the deal you're not getting these
massive sums of money back I mean you
have to have certain situations where
like if if of course it's like if I cast
Denzel Washington okay great
like I'm gonna make this amount of money
but you know to me but if you can't
afford Denzel you can afford someone
who's well known but maybe not as big as
that may not have as much market value
or whatever the case is at the time like
a lot of distributors are not gonna pay
that over a certain amount and so if you
if you create things that are modest
and budget the the chances of you making
back your money plus a large profit is
is very good is very high you know so I
think it's sort of like the Blum House
mentality right like they make their
film sort of certain amount they have
more than enough money to start playing
the hundred million dollar game like but
when they look at sort of like like wow
we're winning you know like we're we're
making these films for between five and
you know ten thousand dollars and I'm a
million I'm sorry five or ten million
dollars and we put some money in the
marketing and we're making these massive
sums so why would we now want to start
pulling out our hair and like playing
this 100 million dollar game where now
we have to make 200 million dollars back
just to break even and you know that's
like a different game up there so in
some cases it's it's a smarter to just
like not overshoot all the time it's not
and I'm not saying in every case every
you know every project is different but
I think that if you can set yourself up
to win from the beginning you know to me
then I think it's smart to do so like if
an investor gives me a million dollars I
don't I wouldn't make one film for a
million dollars I would make three films
for that million dollars you know what I
mean so I just think that it really
depends on the mentality of the person
and how they perceived the industry like
it this is how it really is and this is
how the outside world sort of sees it
and yeah I've always been a realist like
I just think I just never found you know
I'm not the person who because I like to
put the money on the screen like I don't
that having there was a something I was
I heard a long time ago I think it was
from Spielberg and he was talking about
what's in that what's in the frame you
know and about like this is all that
matters like what's in the frame it
doesn't matter it's like two inches
outside of frame there's tape running up
the walls and and you know just all this
weird stuff going on around it what what
matters is what's in the frame and like
that's the approach I take to filmmaking
I don't like to waste money I don't like
to waste investors money so I don't like
to have just a bunch of stuff that you
don't need ten trucks like full of
lobster like you know and then in the
frame none of that value is there like I
like to keep the value in the frame and
and not sort of be wasteful and yeah not
not spending on a bunch of like honey
wagons and being overly exuberant like
outside of it that frame because at the
end of the day when audience sees it
this is all they have to go buy they
don't know what happened on the set they
only know what they see and so I don't
like to throw money at things that
aren't gonna be beneficial to what's in
the frame you know but some people enjoy
that they like the idea of extravagance
on set you know that doesn't mean the
movies gonna be any good but so I just
take like the opposite approach
I think she said something earlier that
really caught my attention was a lot of
people take this time to boast that's
interesting cuz I remember we had that
conversation and we there was something
we were talking about and I don't I'm
always like moving forward like a as an
artist I'm always sort of pushing for it
like I'm constantly pushing forward and
sometimes like I was talking to China he
was like don't forget all the stuff
you've already accomplished like you had
movies and Sam Goody back in the day
like you know like yeah like don't
forget about that stuff like because I'm
always so focused on like never stopping
like I'm I had to sort of learn to
appreciate them the things that I was
had done cuz you know how artists like
we're never satisfied we're always like
no yeah but the next one would be better
like but I can I just got so much more I
want to do and so I'm just in the
artists I just I'm just an artist I just
wants to tell stories like I don't and
have people like appreciate the work but
I I never found I never understood I
guess I kind of understand but I I never
saw the point of like yeah you know you
know like I don't throwing things around
like that like stuff you've done and you
know to me that's not of
yeah I don't think a real artist does
that I think you owe that you allow
people to do that for you but you don't
do it like you don't you know boast and
brag because you no matter how great you
are you didn't do it alone it took a
whole army of people to do it so I to me
that would feel fake like if I'm like
yeah my movie did this and you know we
did a nationwide release and I we made
this and you know it was over here but
I'm like no that was a collective like I
couldn't have done that without those
people so I I just don't
if anything I'm just appreciative of
like having those experiences of working
with so many people and having like it's
beautiful when it's like a family affair
like you feel like it's a family and
you're like everybody's bringing their
best to the table and yeah I just
appreciate those moments but I don't
feel the need to talk like that but I
don't know yeah I just want to just
continue to make art and if people react
to it in a good way then great you know
yeah but ya know this has been the I've
done a lot of interviews it's been the
best interview I've ever had like yeah
like you know it took me back to so many
things that I forgot about you know like
yeah yeah but that's why I love film
covers like that's that's why I love
what you got to do because it's not
about this surface
like you know I mean like it's every
time I watch film cards I don't care who
it is or how much you know you will
always gain a gain knowledge or insight
you know to me because it's and then you
also find like kindred spirits or energy
because you realize that you're not
alone like you're the stuff you did that
you thought you were crazy for doing
someone else has done it someone else
has done a little crazier you thought
making a feature in three weeks with
nuts somebody made one in one day or
somebody you know what I mean so it's
like okay maybe I'm not so crazy maybe
you know like there's a solidarity and
and there's like a brotherhood there
that she didn't know was there you know
and people who had similar feelings and
people who have made similar sacrifices
and and you know it's a it's a it's a
community thing it's not people sort of
lording over you and looking down at you
and like yeah you can't even talk to
these people and they're just up here
and there you know drinking they're like
you know spring water or whatever like
you know it's very much like I feel like
it's like a family communal tribal thing
you know with shown cars like it's like
a tribe of artists you know and that's
really cool